christine ford testifies before the
Senate Judiciary Committee on a party
that she attended 35 or 36 years ago
with maybe five or maybe six or maybe
seven people where Brett Kavanaugh
attempted to grope her or maybe rape her
or maybe murder her in a room with one
other boy or maybe three other boys or I
will will analyze dr. Ford's changing
story and her uncredible testimony then
miracle of miracles Lindsey Graham
becomes the GOP is supposed courageous
senator and finally I will go through
the mailbag that I didn't get to
yesterday I'm Michael Knowles and this
is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
what a buff of a testimony yesterday
what a buff of a hearing what a buff of
a process for the United States Senate
and for confirming judges who was a
mockery was disgraceful every Democrat
should be taken out back and smacked
around a little bit for what they did to
our Republic and what they did to our
constitutional order yesterday was
disgusting we learned a lot from it
though we learned that Ford is not
believable she's not believable I'm not
saying she gave horrible testimony I'm
not saying that you know she totally
broke down her testimony was fine it
probably the people who want to believe
what she says is true probably believe
it still and the people who are
skeptical saw all of the inconsistencies
and contradictions in her testimony they
saw all of the times their lawyer leaned
in and said don't don't answer that no
don'tyou don't answer about how dianne
feinstein referred lawyers to you oh
don't answer about the advice you're
getting from political operatives oh
don't answer about why you didn't do
basic things and she also apparently
misrepresented what her polygraph was we
saw contradictions between her testimony
on that polygraph and the letter she
wrote to dianne feinstein it just broke
down it just wasn't believable and
Cavanagh was believable and it's as
simple as that and anybody telling you
oh you know there but no who knows and
this and that no her testimony was not
believable his was I actually I have
this relative I won't say which relative
of mine this is because I don't want to
ruin her career in her life by just
association with me but she texted me
yesterday and she said I she is left of
Lenin I mean she is she is as far left
as anybody that I know certainly anybody
in my family she texted me and said I
think Cavanaugh is being falsely accused
and I said well if you're saying it then
it's certainly true and that's the
impression you get his testimony was
very powerful
it was hard to watch it was hard to
watch because it was pretty emotional he
couldn't keep the emotion back he was
very credible and she I don't know if
she's a crazy person or if she's miss
remembering something
she's clearly a damaged individual just
from not only from her behavior but the
various the various therapies that we're
talking about did she where all of this
came from
apparently so we'll talk about
all of that his/her behavior was pretty
weird
I should note I had a great time last
night I mean I'm you might notice I'm
not in the studio right now I'm still in
Pittsburgh we had a great time at
Franciscan University of Steubenville
the students were incredible super super
smart I I really shouldn't recommend
this university to you because then a
bunch of like yet the word is gonna get
out a bunch of lefties are gonna go in
you know they're gonna ruin the whole
place but it was incredible is really
really impressed with very serious kids
super smart well-educated so it was
great great to hang out with them we
talked about the simple joys of being
right we're in a more speeches coming up
on my cofán campus tour with UF we're
gonna be going on October 24th and 25th
to Grand Canyon University and I think
we're going to Michigan after that
though I could be mistaken but they're
coming up so if you want me to come to
your school get your request in through
yeah because we're filling up fast so if
you didn't watch the testimony yesterday
if you to watch the hearings lucky you
oh man this was really I mean during my
show I was watching the testimony while
I was supposed to be writing my speech I
was watching the testimony it was all
drama you want to be entertained you got
entertained it was really hard to watch
if you missed it you you can watch about
ten seconds of the testimony you'll
understand what the whole thing was here
is Brett Kavanaugh federal judge DC
Circuit Judge Supreme Court nominee
being grilled on the meaning of the word
book from his 1982 high school yearbook
have you I don't know if it's buffed or
boofed how do you pronounce that I
refers to flatulence we were 16 okay
[Laughter]
that was from Sheldon Whitehouse
Sheldon White has a pure hack a pure
partisan they all have been in this I
sort of give Kamala Harris
and Cory Booker a little bit of leeway
because they're running for president
and it's still cheap and shallow but at
least there's a purpose to it but dick
Blumenthal
a dick durbin Sheldon Whitehouse they're
behaving like monsters I mean they're
behaving like hysterical little monsters
it's awful it makes a mockery of our
process and so yesterday after all of
these hearings Sheldon Whitehouse leans
in he goes I want to ask you
about your high school yearbook from
1982 and Kavanaugh basically says yeah
go right ahead
okay the United States Senate Judiciary
Committee Supreme Court nominee okay
let's talk about my yearbook
you know and so then you know what's the
meaning of the word buh and Kavanaugh
just knocks it out of the park and it
this highlights it they're asking about
these little trip did you ever have beer
in high school yes senator I would I I
was a high school student yeah back when
the drinking age was eighteen actually
so it's even more defensible did you
ever drink when you were a young man
yeah because on account if I was a young
man so yes I did
idiots the way you know that this was a
really serious hearing other than
Democrats asking about how many times
brick Cavanaugh flagellated when he was
16 the other way you know is a really
serious hearing is that they had Alyssa
Milano there
that's a they had Alyssa Milano she was
brought in as a guest of Feinstein or
somebody and she's sitting there behind
cabin hawk I don't mmm like that's a
really that's a serious person a really
serious senator is invites Alyssa Milano
to the testimony absolutely outrageous
in the weight that they all I mean it
was so awful Chuck Grassley deserves a
lot of blame here this never should have
happened it never should have been
brought to this they they were so nice
everybody on the committee was so nice
to Christine Ford and they were so
hostile and so unfair and so outrageous
to Brett Kavanaugh I had any Coulter on
my show a couple days ago a few days ago
and I asked her about dr. Ford and and
in her typical you know subdued staid
way said that she was obviously a lefty
lunatic nutcase out of her mind
and I I thought that was a little unfair
at the time not quite so sure now after
that testimony here is how all of the
Senators hear the hard questions that
they gave to dr. Ford making these
allegations trying to ruin a man's life
keep him off the Supreme Court take a
fair judicial pick away from a sitting
president duly elected president here
that here's the tough way that they
grilled her you know you are not on
chocolate
you are not on trial you are sitting
here before members of the United States
Senate Judiciary Committee because you
had the courage to come forward because
as you have said you believed it was
your civic duty she most certainly is on
trial she this was the line they all
repeated this because they all wanted to
get their little clip for their campaign
ads so they said and you I just want you
to know you're not on trial you're not
under you are on trial
sheeeit dr. Ford is on trial she is
making a really serious outrageous
allegation from something that allegedly
happened 36 years ago an outrageous well
I mean she's she's calling him a rapist
and a murderer
now obviously the thing she describes
was he groped her but she's saying he
tried to rape me he tried to murder me I
thought he was gonna kill me
accidentally whatever you're on trial
your credibility is on trial here and it
needs to be seriously scrutinized but
the Democrats have done away with due
process they've done away with the
rights of the accused they're tweeting I
believe all women why would you believe
all women do is there something about
those double X chromosomes that makes
you incapable of lying what are you
talking about they say why would a woman
lie I don't know I couldn't tell you but
we're through several cases just a few
days ago meant more than several cases
of major rape allegations that turned
out to be hoaxes the biggest rape cases
in recent history into two biggest rape
cases were major hoaxes maybe the three
Tawana Brawley in the 80s which al
Sharpton made his career on the Duke
Lacrosse case obviously ruined those
kids lives and the UVA case the UVA is
another example this was a major news
story published in Rolling Stone it was
a lie I don't know why would people make
up false allegations psychosis revenge
politics convenience I don't know it
happens a lot though and and some you
just couldn't explain why so I don't
know but they say I believe you why why
what evidence is she presented she's
contradicted herself and we'll get to
those examples in a second so but the
Democrats had to try to pick a lane here
because they tried to do two things at
once and it did not work the one that
the first tactic was to say doctor for
she's dr. Ford she's not mrs. Ford she's
doctor
has a phd she's a psychologist she okay
she's a clinical psychologist doctor
doctor for serious academic published a
lot of things
here's feinstein going down that path at
the start of the hearings I have to say
when I saw your CV I was extremely
impressed you have a bachelor's degree
from the University of North Carolina
Chapel Hill two masters degrees one from
Stanford and one from Pepperdine and a
PhD from the University of Southern
California better known to senator
Harris and I as USC you are a professor
affiliated with both Stanford University
and Palo Alto University you have
published over 65 peer-reviewed articles
and have received numerous awards for
your work and research and therefore
you're telling the truth in relating the
truth correctly about an allegation that
happened 36 years ago that no one has
ever heard of until five seconds ago
because you know you you go to Palo Alto
University or whatever by the way I
don't remember them introducing brick
cabin all this way I'm pretty impressed
with Brett Kavanaugh his CV Yale
undergrad Yale Law School clerks for the
Supreme Court fed staff secretary to the
president worked on the Ken Starr
investigation which is what a lot of
this is about because the Clinton world
is getting revenge and Democrats are
getting revenge for that whole episode
and they're trying to flip it on a sex
issue then what federal judge then you
know he's on one of the most powerful
courts in the country DC Circuit Court
of Appeals and now a Supreme Court
nominee that's a pretty good CV I don't
remember them to all but she attends
Palo Alto University or she's affiliated
with Palo Alto okay Wow incredible so
the reason they did that is because they
want to say that she's this serious
person look she's a professor okay how
there were a note no crazy people ever
become professors right no like we don't
have an entire character trope in
popular culture of the wacky crazy
professor pie-in-the-sky politicized
whatever no she's a professor of Palo
Alto University she couldn't be lying so
they go down that path they want to say
she's a super serious person but then
they realized they have to make her
really likable and sweet and innocent
and cute so they're trying to do two
things at once and it doesn't quite work
when I heard at the top of these
hearings
one of the first things Christine for
had said made me really question what
was going on here here's right at the
top of her hearings when they introduced
her I want to say that to everybody that
she has asked for anytime you asked for
a break you get a break anytime there's
something that you need you don't have
just ask us and you can have as much
time for your opening statement as you
want and and just generally let us know
if there's any issues proceed please
Thank You senator Grassley I think after
I read my opening statement I anticipate
needing some caffeine if that is
available okay oh is she I just
anticipate well if you anticipated it
then bring a cup of coffee to the
hearing you anticipated you anticipate
it or have a have a shot of espresso
before you sit down
no I just might need some caffeine I
might need a break after this if you
guys start grilling me I don't want to
answer those questions
hee hee hee hee I'm so cute they're
trying to play it both ways and by the
way so we should be very blunt about
this because there's the question of
this political disgusting disgraceful
circus where they ripped down a good man
who's never had any of these allegations
laid against him until he was in the
position to swing the court to be more a
right wing to be more originalist they
asked why didn't this happen with neil
Gorsuch neil Gorsuch was replacing
Antonin Scalia it's hard to get more
hardcore and originalist than Scalia so
it doesn't change the makeup of the
court Brett Kavanaugh is replacing
Anthony Kennedy Kennedy is the swing
vote Kennedy was the squish Brett
Kavanaugh appears to be more Rock ribs
than him this will fundamentally change
the composition of the court and they're
out for blood
this is largely about Democrats abortion
lust this is largely about how insistent
they are that we preserve the fictitious
constitutional right to kill a baby in
the womb but that's why they're reacting
this way to Cavanaugh instead of course
in every lefty who's bringing up that
comparison knows it every major lefty
every lefty analyst or elected official
and they're just being obtuse but as to
the matter did Brett Kavanaugh grope
this girl super drunk in 1982 or when
we have no reason to believe that that's
true everyone who has been called on is
a witness to the event or around the
time has said this isn't true or I don't
remember or I've never met Brett
Kavanaugh they including the girl that
she says was there so but but also I
don't care I actually don't care what
happened to 1982 I feel bad for her if
something happened in 1982 I wish you'd
told someone sooner so whatever guy was
being aggressive with her could have
been punished for it but I don't care I
know nobody cares by the way nobody
could not a single person on that
Judiciary Committee cares not a single
Democrat who's demagoguing cares they
are just making an issue out of this to
keep an originalist off of the court but
she says it's her civic duty
she says it's it's her civic duty to
come here and stop this guy from being
on the Supreme Court cuz he'll have too
much power where was she when he made it
to the DC Circuit Court of Appeals one
of the most powerful courts in the
country where was she then was it that's
one of the most powerful courts in the
country if she thought that this was so
important to keep him off the Supreme
Court why wouldn't you keep him off the
DC Circuit is she in that Court in many
ways has more patsies more cases right
thank you no we see the big headline or
banner cases make it up to the Supreme
Court but most cases don't make it up to
the Supreme Court if it was your civic
duty why not stop him then doesn't
doesn't add up but it's certainly been
demagogued by Democrats so they they try
to play the cutesy thing she's either
the super serious sober academic or
she's really really cutesy and they
should have picked a lane because I
don't think it played very well but then
she she makes one of the most stunning
statements of the day I'll let her speak
for herself
we're here to accommodate you now I'm
used to being collegial go ahead
oh you're used to being calm used to
being collegial that's why I'm going to
burn down a man's life over 36 year old
allegations that are refuted by every
one that I occasionally say were there
even though I changed the number of
people who were there left and right but
I'm collegial I'm collegial I'm gonna
burn I'm gonna I'm going to take away
from a duly elected president his right
his constitutional right to put a judge
on the court I'm gonna take that away
because I'm collegial and chuck grassley
for his part the whole time go and we
can get you in would you like a back rub
would you like how about is the lighting
in the room okay give me a break
so pathetic thank goodness we have
Lindsey Graham to be the spine of the
GOP we'll get to him in a second but
outrageous a brazen statement I'm you
I'm used to being collegial not
collegial at all this is horrific what's
happening and if you look if something
happened if you've got evidence that
something happened bring the evidence
okay bring it but you don't have any
evidence and actually the corroborating
people say it didn't happen so then she
gets into the meat of her accusation
here it is I believed he was going to
rape me I tried to yell for help when I
did Brett put his hand over my mouth to
stop me from yelling this is what
terrified me the most and this had the
most lasting impact on my life it was
hard for me to breathe and I thought
that Brett was accidentally going to
kill me so what is the allegation now
the allegation first was that he groped
her he was super drunk and he tried to
get her shirt off and he you know was
kind of grabbing her on a bed then the
allegation was he tried to rape me
nothing she's described suggests he's
tried to rape her or raped her then she
says he was going to kill me what what
are you talking about this is why the
senator is brought up yesterday
well it's tell your truth Cory Booker
said it pretty tell your truth your
truth we hear the left say this all the
time not the truth your truth the reason
they say this is because they know that
the objective facts they can't stand on
them at all they had it totally knocks
him down so it has to be all about
subjective feeling
did he grope you or did he murder to try
to murder you which was it well I felt I
felt he was gonna murder me I thought he
was gonna go slaughter my whole family
maybe go commit genocide somewhere I
thought I pretty sure I just felt
because I felt and I believed that 36
years ago this guy was going to commit
genocide prove me wrong
that's what I felt that's my truth
that's my truth so it went on like that
there is no evidence that Brett
Kavanaugh did anything to Christine Ford
in 1982 or at any other time the only
suggestion that he did that comes from
Christine Ford whose testimony has a lot
of holes in it an end end is uncredible
just by virtue of the fact that it's
only coming up now
five seconds before this guy is going to
make it to the Supreme Court with a
political agenda during a particularly
heated moment when the Supreme Court has
a lot of power and the left is totally
ginned up against President Trump there
are a lot of contradictions in this
testimony let's just go through them
very quickly John Nolte put up a good
piece on this this morning in the letter
to Feinstein she says that there were
five people at the party me and four
others then in the statement that she
passed her polygraph test on we'll get
to that polygraph in just one second she
said it was four boys and a couple of
girls which means that at the minimum
there were six people there and possibly
seven people there because in the first
one she said me and four others then she
says four boys a couple of girls she
including herself and a couple of girls
even if she is it still contradicts her
letter to Dianne Feinstein possibly
certainly by one person maybe by two
people then there's the matter of the
therapists notes in the therapists notes
from this session that she apparently
had in 2012 30 years after the alleged
event happened and six years ago she
said that there were four people in the
room during the attempted rape then when
she spoke to The Washington Post she
said that there were two people in the
room during the attempted rape or the
murder of the groping or whatever it was
in at any given point in her testimony
then she says she had a fear of flying
so this was the reason that she couldn't
come testify in DC and thus Judiciary
Committee offered to fly to California
so she said she had a fear of flying but
and the lawyer her lawyer said that she
could not fly because she has a fear of
confined spaces that came from this
alleged traumatic event 36 years ago but
in her first letter to Feinstein she
said that she was vacationing in the Mid
Atlantic until August 7th and then would
be in California
on August 10th so she appeared I don't
think she took a horse-and-buggy there
she's apparently flying she flew up to
New Hampshire she's she's we've seen her
flying all over the place the lawyer
statement was and she couldn't testify
because she has a fear of flying so that
just is not true right it or if she has
a fear of flying it's not a debilitating
fear it's a fear that she overcomes
constantly so it wouldn't be an excuse
for her not to come to DC so that's just
a bald-faced lie somewhere in there she
also won't release the therapy notes so
the therapy notes
don't mention Kavanagh that when she
talked about this in 2012 according to
those therapy notes she won't mention
Kavanagh but she she won't answer
whether she gave these notes to The
Washington Post
so she was asked this yesterday during
his testimony and she said oh I just
don't remember you don't remember this
was less than eight weeks ago surely
your short-term memory must be really
pretty bad your long-term memory might
be a little bad too because the story
keeps changing did you give them the
therapy notes or not she won't hand over
the therapy notes now why not I don't
know what's in those therapy notes
what's it look but let's have a 7th FBI
investigation of brick Avenue let's do
that we he's only only had six so four
probably something's got through there
but she won't turn over her therapy
notes and then finally Ford named it
when the latest version of her story she
named the three men and the one girl at
that party all of the three men deny it
no recollection or categorically deny it
and the the girl that she names they're
her friend says that she has never ever
met Brett Kavanaugh so anybody who could
corroborate says it didn't happen
including the girlfriend including the
girl who was there says not only was
Brett Kavanaugh not there I have never
met him
so no evidence whatsoever falls apart is
Christine Ford lying maybe is she
mistaken maybe is she a total lunatic
maybe I just don't know I don't know her
testimony was a little weird
she wasn't dancing on the table or
anything but we can we can deduce from
all of that testimony that she's not
credible Kavanaugh however performed
very well I'll just give you in case you
missed it I'll give you a little taste
of his opening statement I have been a
good judge and for this nomination
another FBI background investigation on
another American Bar Association
investigation 31 hours of hearings 65
senator meetings 1200 written questions
more than all previous Supreme Court
nominees combined throughout that entire
time throughout my 53 years and seven
months on this earth until last week no
one ever accused me of any kind of
sexual misconduct
no one ever a lifetime a lifetime of
public service and a lifetime of
high-profile public service at the
highest levels of American government
and never a hint of anything of this
kind and that's because nothing of this
kind ever happens pretty powerful stuff
and now so he obviously denies it he
gives some evidence he says I've never
been accused to Sabre in my life until
five seconds when I was threatening
Democrats but listen to what he tells
you he says I have gone through more
than all of the previous Supreme Court
nominees combined testimony
investigations this and that this tells
you something about the government
breaking down about the process breaking
down and it's not Republicans who are
doing it it's not Republicans who use
the nuclear option on judicial nominees
it was Democrats it was Harry Reid he
started this the Republicans are not to
blame for this the Democrats are to
blame and it's despicable and it's
disgusting and it's bad for the
government because it just wait oh just
wait until the Democrats get a judicial
nominee up I want Republicans to destroy
that person I want them to destroy them
ruin to them wreck them humiliate them
and torture them not because I think
that's a good thing to do to the
judicial nominee I don't know anything
about the judicial nominee but because
the Republicans cannot unilaterally
disarm we can't it is awful to the
process it's unfair it's immoral to the
people who go up for this for people who
have judicial nominations or any other
appointments or nominations it's unfair
to so debase our process this way and
Democrats are going to keep on doing it
because they have no moral feeling
whatsoever certainly those people on the
judicial on the Judiciary Committee and
so we should not
laterally to storm we should give them a
taste of their own medicine Republicans
take the high road they try to take the
high road
I get it I feel I like that but it the
process of politics is pretty ugly and
you have to get your hands a little bit
dirty if you're gonna do it they should
wreck the next person give the Democrats
a taste of their own medicine because
it's despicable what they did to him
Kavanagh then won the Audience over when
he mentioned one part where he got
choked up it was visibly it was
difficult for him to speak here he is
I'm not questioning that dr. Ford may
have been sexually assaulted by some
person in some place at some time but I
have never done this to her or to anyone
that's not who I am it is not who I was
I am innocent of this charge I intend no
ill will to dr. Ford in her family the
other night Ashley and my daughter Liza
said their prayers and little Liza all
10 years old said to Ashley we should
pray for the woman
powerful stuff and by the way some
people you know they watch these things
and they see when people are putting on
a shaky voice or they're pretending or
they're acting or whatever that wasn't
acting if that was acting then that guy
is Brando you know that guy that guy is
really something else at that were there
that's him very very genuine other parts
of dr. Ford's testimony I'm not I'm not
so sure I'm not accusing her of
performing exactly but it was a little
it was less credible let's put it that
way
so it was a foot became a force they
kept asking him about his high school
yearbook they I you saw the book thing
at the beginning they as and so the book
thing is absurd but it also pilot it
highlights not just the absurdity of
that questioning but broadly about
asking people what they did in high
school who cares this man has been a
federal judge for over a decade this man
has worked for the president in a pretty
high-level role this this is a serious
but why who cares what they do are they
gonna ask him about his high school
basketball scores who can what relevance
is that to anybody so it became a it
became a farce
and then then they go on to mark judge
you've heard of mark judge he's this
conservative guy he was also accused of
being at the party and apparently he had
a pretty big alcoholism problem he wrote
a book where he put his friends names in
it from high school you know and but he
like changed their names so it was you
know he'd changed them slightly but he'd
you know give them a little shout out so
here is Leahy senator leahy absolute
decrepit corrupt chrome asking about his
friendship with Mark judge and it gets
pretty ridiculous
sure this the author to book time wasted
tales of a Gen X drunk he references a
bart of Kavanagh vomiting in someone's
car during beach leagues and passing out
zette you he's talking about senator
mark judge was technologies that use
he's talking about I'll explain if you
let me proceed please
judge was a friend of ours in high
school who developed a very serious
drinking problem an addiction problem
that lasted decades and was very
difficult for him to escape from and he
nearly died and then he developed then
he had leukemia as well on top of trying
to get a straight answer from you under
oath are you referring to yes or no
that's you'd have to ask him well I
agree or you barked Oh Cavanaugh it was
one of the names in this guy's
fictionalized account of his youth where
he threw in his friends names are you
Bartow Cavanaugh no dummy I'm Brett
Kavanaugh you have my name is right it's
written on the nameplate it's written up
what are you insinuating there's a
fictional account of fictionalized
account written by a guy who was
apparently drunk thread a lot of high
school as part of his rehabilitation and
you're going to say well in that in that
fictionalized account he wrote where he
talked about a Bartow Cavanaugh is that
you I don't I don't know man I don't
cares who kept like I don't know if I
don't know if the fictional character in
this book is referring to me obviously
it's a got a similar name Bartow
Cavanaugh so he's clearly playing on the
name for the name of the of the
character but or we deduce from that
that this is some journalistic account
of their high school days of course not
here's a sign of the Apocalypse then
we're gonna have to probably gonna have
to go and get two mailbag Lindsey Graham
comes out and wins the day this was true
moral clarity and it took moral courage
to do it and I got to tell you if you
would ask me two years ago if the
strongest people in the United States
Senate the toughest rock-ribbed can
effect of conservatives were going to be
Lindsey Graham and Mitch McConnell I
would have laughed at you but I don't
know cocaine's a hell of a drug you know
cocaine Mitch is coming out strong
khofifah is a hell of a drug - and the
Lindsey Graham has really gave it to
them here is Lindsey Graham for all
intents and purposes ending the hearing
Warren at FBI investigation you could
have come to us what you want to do is
destroy this guy's life hold this seat
open and hope you win in 2020
you said that not me you've got nothing
to apologize for
when you see Sotomayor and Kagan tell
them it Lindsay said all because I voted
for them I would never do to them what
you've done to this guy this is the most
unethical sham since I've been in
politics and if you really wanted to
know the truth you sure as hell wouldn't
have done what you've done to this guy
are you a gang rapist
no I cannot imagine what you and your
family are going through
boy y'all want power god I hope you
never get it I hope the American people
can see through this sham that you knew
about it and you held it you had no
intention of protecting dr. fort
no she's as much of a victim as you are
god I hate to say it cuz these have been
my friends but let me tell you when it
comes to this you're looking for a fair
process you came to the wrong town at
the wrong time my friend beautifully
said absolutely right in Cavanaugh then
at the very end of the hearings they say
uh as a man or you believe in God
Cavanaugh he says yes says look me in
the eye tell me you didn't do this I did
not do this that's how it ends so what's
the take away is she lying I don't know
I'm more convinced that she's lying
after the hearing than I was before but
I don't know who's to say you can't
possibly say is she credible certainly
not 100% not I and I'm much more
convinced of that after the hearing than
I was before Democrats think this looks
good for them they think that this is
gonna play really well with women
they're sucking up to women they think
that they can split off women from the
GOP coalition I don't know if they
realize that women have husbands and
fathers and sons I'm not sure if they
realize that that maybe women in America
don't want men to be able to have their
lives and reputations and careers
destroyed over utterly unsubstantiated
in fact in many cases discredited
thirty-five-year-old accusations I do
I know I wonder if they know that it's
such an obvious miscarriage of justice I
don't think this plays very well they
think that they can get away with this
too we I mean if you just followed the
Twitter conversation yesterday because
it plays into their intersectionality
narrative so they you know I think
Lindsey Graham might have you been joked
about this yesterday they tried to do it
to Clarence Thomas it was and he played
the the speech of a high-tech lynching
said this is a high-tech lynching for
uppity blacks Brett Kavanaugh can't do
this and by the ideology of
intersectionality the worst people on
earth are straight white men who think
that they're men and they are the
oppressors and everyone else should gang
up and band together intersectionally
and overthrow them it's a particular
Marxist ideology that views all of
history as this sort of struggle it's
it's unfair obviously it's it's just
it's just as bad to attack a straight
white guy as it is to attack a gay
transsexual black woman I don't know but
but that's how they view the world they
think they're gonna be able to hit it
that way I think people are sick of it
there was an ad in The New York Times
sixteen hundred men purchased an ad in
the New York Times to say that we
believe women we believe accusers all
right that's not how our process works
guys you don't just get to accuse
somebody we know I we went through it
all last week there are a lot of false
rape accusations major ones national
ones it's very bad because those false
accusations really damage people who
have legitimately so actually suffered
from sexual assault or any other kind of
crime and it damages them it damages the
credibility of those crimes but that's
the world we live in there are fake
accusations people are innocent until
proven guilty no matter what the
Democrats want to do right now the
latest update I have is flake is voting
YES corkers voting yes and and so it'll
get out of committee
some people are unsure as to how it will
perform in the Senate but it looks like
this will proceed to a Senate vote I
hope he gets through and I can't wait
for brick havenõt Associate Justice
Kavanagh to be the guy who overturns roe
v wade to be the swing vote that's gonna
be beautiful I cannot wait and I can't
wait for that next Democrat judicial
nominee because we're gonna have a good
time with that we've got a lot of
mailbag to get to I've got a second
look in YouTube go over to daily
wire.com what do you get me the under
cleavage of the Ben Shapiro show you
can't ask questions in the mailbag which
is coming up and I think most
importantly right now
you'll get your leftist years tumblr
which is going to I mean get a look you
I look obviously I I want you to
subscribe to the website you should
subscribe probably four or five times
because you're going to need four or
five different tumblers for what happens
when Associate Justice Breck Avenel gets
to that bench go to daily wire calm
we'll be right back
okay first question from Jamie hey
Michael do you think spectral evidence
should be admissible in court given
their support for Christine Ford the
Democrats seem to think so
I was curious what you think about its
validity thanks love the show Jamie
spectral evidence is the evidence from
dreams and hallucinations that was used
during the Salem witch trials and
apparently it is apparently it is I I
don't think it should be admissible
obviously but the Democrats do and the
Democrats are half the country this also
gets to an issue that we've talked about
before which is the neo-paganism the neo
cultish nests of the modern left because
everybody's got to serve somebody
everybody has a religious view so if you
don't worship God the God of the Bible
then you're going to worship the
environment the nature God the the
ecosystem that whatever this or that or
the yoga Richard like Matt Walsh talks
about yoga as paganism he's arriving
there's this um and these kind of
rituals to it which are religious in
nature and you're gonna go and you're
gonna descend into man's natural state
which is paganism and and unreason and
you're going to you're going to have
Democrats demanding spectral evidence be
admitted in court I mean they've they
have all but done that during these
hearings so I might not support it but
that's the way we're headed from
Augustine or Augustine I don't know
hello dearest Michael I hope it's
Augustine what's dearest Michael I have
found myself relying solely on
conservative news sources such as The
Daily wire and Fox News are there any
good left-wing news sources that I
should look at to balance my news yes
the Wall Street Journal leans left and
it's a news reporting and it's good the
Financial Times leans left probably more
left and it's reporting it's good those
are obviously they have more of a focus
on business for political left-wing
outlets I can't think of good ones the
New Republic used to be okay that fell
apart a few years ago no I can't really
think of good ones but what that leaves
you to do is that means you have to read
all the crazy ones that means you should
read voxcom even though it's awful in
their total hacks
you should read who else I don't know
Mother Jones whatever you know read the
left-wing crazy people because what it
will at least do is when you read it
outlets that have a particular opinion
on the right a preference for the right
then when you read the lefties you'll be
able to get probably new talking points
new language new ways of talking about
things and you can dismiss that which is
absurd but it will give you a better
perspective because it's not so much
different facts that they're presenting
you probably get all the facts if you
read the right-wing ones but you're
getting different language in the
left-wing ones and those different
languages those different vocabularies
give you a different perspective so at
least you can understand what the left
is saying and you can answer their
arguments you should always be able to
answer their arguments the benefit of
being a left-wing culture is that you're
constantly having to defend your views
and answer other people's arguments you
know how they think but they don't know
how you think and one way to ensure that
remains true is you got to read those
crazy lefties and then you can answer
them from Joseph mr. Knowles
loved the show honest question why are
you for individual nation states against
a super national global government but
for a super national global religious
bureaucracy Allah the Catholic Church
doesn't huge bureaucracy breed
corruption is in the church the last
place we would want corruption
especially at a global scale isn't
global religious corruption what we're
seeing now in the Catholic Church with
this disgrace of a pope and bracing
leftist values and defending child
molesters well I'm not sure that that
last part is fair he's protected people
apparently knowing of abuse of priests
and seminarians but I don't think
there's evidence that he protected
people that he knew were abused children
wooden churches based on one's
conscientious interpretation of the
Bible be a better model Christ calls for
unity but does that mean bureaucratic
unity doesn't the spirit transcend
nation language while still keeping them
intact anyways I want your two cents PS
I love what you've done with Shapiro's
broom-closet you've really made it your
own
Joseph well it to answer your question
no I won't become a Protestant your your
care no I've actually it's a good
question you raise why do I support
individual nation states against
imperial government but I support what
an imperial church a global church a
universal Church which is the meaning of
the word Catholic the the reason for
that ah then the nation-states came
about after the Peace of Westphalia in
1648 it came about because Protestants
and Catholics fought a photo series of
wars and the Protestants won there they
at least didn't lose which means they
won if there were in an empire that were
a Catholic Empire or Christian Empire
what christened of used to be before the
modern age before the Treaty of
Westphalia before the Protestant
revolution if there were a United
Christendom I could support that
political order it certainly worked well
enough for Europe when Europe was united
but today we don't have a United
Christendom these super national
governments these giant Imperial
bureaucracies are not Christian they're
post Christian their secular their the
European Union they're the United
Nations they're the International
Criminal Court they're not they're not
christened them the United Nations
doesn't make sense anyway because you
you can't unite everybody that's the
same as not having everybody be United
it's the the part of national groups and
tribal groups and clan groups is that
you are different from people and you
have different interests and different
backgrounds and traditions so that's
absurd but even the European Union if
the European Union were going to be run
by I don't know Charles Borromeo or
somebody or is gonna be run by some you
know strong Christian then perhaps but
that isn't the case so I and and that's
not coming back I don't suspect that's
going to come back as for why I remain
Catholic it's because I think the
Catholic Church was instituted by Christ
people will ask why don't you go to a
church that just just believes the Bible
I say I I attend the church and I'm a
member of the church that wrote the
Bible now part of the Bible Bible Bible
insistence is is that this is a product
of the Protestant revolution and later
stages of it but I don't worship the
Bible
I'd love Scripture but I don't worship
the Bible the Bible is not the Word of
God Christ is the Word of God he says so
in the book which is the Bible so I I
don't worship the Bible the Bible is is
wonderful it's it's square
it's revelations divine sure but it's
not the whole thing and I think as
Chesterton says heresy is not when you
promote vice / virtue but when you
promote one virtue to the exclusion of
all the others so we wouldn't want to
exclude we wouldn't want to have only
works to the exclusion of faith or only
or you know only grace to the exclusion
of freewill we wouldn't want to exclude
these things only justice to the
exclusion of mercy well all of these
things can be held together in God and
so I despite all of the many problems in
my church I remain a member of it
okay we've got time for I think one more
to the local papist of The Daily wire
how do we Catholics work around the
whole thou shalt not make unto the any
grave grave an image thing it seems like
we pretend there's an asterisk on that
commandment that leads to the fine print
where it says unless I come to earth in
human form at some point then all bets
are off I don't see any reason this
should be a law that only applies to
Jews like eating kosher bread on the
context it's presented in but we seem to
violate it pretty heavily especially
since we don't just make graven images
of Christ which I can almost make an
exception for but also regular mortals
like Mary and the Saints and even beings
like angels how do we square this
practice with the Bible well you've got
to read the Bible more carefully you
talk about the asterisk being added to
the scripture the asterisk is in the
scripture it's in exodus itself I think
it's Exodus 20 where we see don't don't
make any graven image and then in Exodus
25 God tells Moses to create statues of
the angels cherubim and Seraphim he says
make these statues put the constructive
statues
he tells Moses to make make a serpent
and put him on us put them on a stick
crucify the Serpent and this will be
assigned to the Israelites all shallows
are clear and one cannot read one verse
of the Bible out of context you have to
read it in context in this quick case
the context is in the same book and it's
only a handful of chapters away the
reason that we don't make a graven image
is so that you don't worship the image
but we don't worship images we they are
tools of veneration there we have images
I don't I don't worship other images
that I see and I don't worship statues
of Jesus or Mary or Saint Joseph
I don't worship Mary as it is I pray to
Mary
but I don't worship Mary and no faithful
Catholic does and it's never been a part
of Catholic doctrine and it remains not
that way all shallows are clear before
we go I'm just getting this in now it
seems that flake flaky Jeff Flake has
allowed the vote out of the Judiciary
Committee but he is now saying he will
not vote for Cavanaugh until an FBI
investigation happens Jeff Flake
continuing to prove himself the single
worst person who's ever called himself a
Republican what a jerk to use a to be
polite what a jerk
so I guess we're gonna get the 7th FBI
investigation now the first six the
first six that's not that didn't work by
the way as a judge Cavanaugh said during
his testimony FBI investigations are not
conclusive this is what this is the
investigation I'll do it for you now
senator flake hey mr. Cavanaugh what do
you think happened I didn't do any of
this hey Christine Ford what do you
think happened I think he tried to
murder me and take me up to Planet
Zebulon six okay all right dr. Ford
that's fine mr. judge what do you think
happened didn't happen hey that girl
that Ford said was there whose name I
forget what do you think happened I've
never met Brett Kavanaugh so that didn't
happen okay APJ what do you think
happened didn't happen okay that's the
investigation I just hey I saved
everybody a lot of time I did the FBI
investigation please somebody forward
this to Senator Jeff Flake along with my
restraint at what I would like to say to
him two words not happy birthday that is
that's really frustrating we'll talk
about it more on Monday
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
semia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you